a product that doesn't work with lots of
features is infinitely worse
than a product with one feature that
works
and again like let's play that out
let's play that out right imagine if
it's like they were like you get health
care and you get benefits and you get
401k and payroll and none of those
features work and sometimes we lose the
money
yes
it's like you would hate them you would
hate that
that sounds like verizon or something
you know exactly
hey this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell and welcome to rookie mistakes
we asked yc founders for their rookie
mistakes so we could share them with you
and help you avoid them
here's the first mistake that was
written in
in my company we tried to accommodate
more than one use case in our product
before nailing
a single use case and proving out that
they even existed business
serving that customer
yeah this this is super common it's
definitely a problem we call this
boiling the ocean right it's you're
trying to do something that's basically
impossible or intractable
and all of your instincts are to build a
complete fully formed product without
getting a single user in your mind you
have this elaborate plan
and so your your plan to start
the elaborate plan is to build it all at
once before getting a single user i
think that every founder starts their
company with the lie in their head
that they know
about what their customer wants and they
know how to solve the problem
and the more you build before putting
your product in front of a user the more
you just let that lie go wild whereas as
soon as you get something in front of a
user you can actually learn
how many of my hypotheses were correct
and how much of this stuff was just the
lie that got me started doing my company
a useful lie but maybe not the best lie
if you want to solve your user's problem
i also think there's a little bit of
i'll invent the term google itis like
people looking at companies that they
use today
and not understanding what they looked
like at the beginning
yeah they're just looking at google and
a current product
you're like oh we're the next amazon so
we're gonna build everything amazon has
and not hey when amazon started it was
like a really simple website that just
sold books it didn't do anything else
like i think it didn't even do that that
well wasn't that
fair
let's talk about some other examples
though you were mentioning that open c
is a good example of something that
started super simple yeah i mean look
open c is a company in the zeitgeist
it's really famous it feels like it came
out of nowhere if you're like a like a
normal person you're like wow open c
what a huge deal well open c was in yc
in 2018
and
you know
it was a rough start they they changed
their idea they were working on
something else to begin with and they
pivoted into open c and they actually
spent something like a year to two years
grinding it out with this really simple
website
that just let you buy and sell nfts and
like barely worked
and they shipped tons of features they
shipped like once a day or once a week
constantly
they didn't build their own wallet like
if you use openc today you'll notice
this you have to use a third-party
wallet there's all these other things
they didn't build
and by grinding away and being super
focused on the simple use case
they got something that people wanted
they got network effects and then boom
we all woke up one day and this is one
of the hottest companies you know
in the world and everyone wants to
invest and you know they're worth
billions of dollars well
don't forget
the two or three years they
were grinding away in obscurity
just trying to make the dang thing work
doing the simplest thing that had
basically no features the feature was a
website
to buy an nft
and transfer to someone else
you know what i'm saying it still has a
lot of work to do on the basics before
they add really complex features there's
a lot more basic work to do on that
thing and so
again like the story here is the reason
that thing worked is they started simple
and they made the simple thing work and
now they're adding more complexity to it
and so if someone wanted to like compete
with them or make an nft startup they
should be doing the simple fundamentals
first and not
try to get feature parody
with with all these other companies
first you know
i totally agree i remember you know when
gusto
um
went through yc because they were
actually in my second batch in winter
12.
and another example of you know if you
look at gusto today you would say oh
you can do payroll you could do benefits
you can see your org chart you can do
401k like it's like this
tool chest full of amazing hr tools
when gusto started it was a company
named zen payroll it did exactly one
thing your payroll back then
if you didn't use zen payroll you'd have
to call up adp
and adp would bring someone to your
office for you to sign stuff
so that you could run payroll and then
every month you had to call someone on
the phone and say yes
i do want to run payroll this month like
like that was state of the art and then
gusto said we can just do that online
and all that's all it's going to do and
you're going to love it and you're going
to sign up and you're going to forget
about it because that's what good
payroll is right you forget about it and
so
like imagine a version of of gust or zen
payroll that had a lot of features but
constantly didn't
pay your employees
like like a broken version a product
that doesn't work with lots of features
is infinitely worse
than a product with one feature that
works
and again like let's play that out
let's play that out right imagine if
it's like they were like you get
healthcare and you get benefits and you
get 401k and payroll and none of those
features were and sometimes we lose the
money
yes and it's like you would hate them
you would hate that
that sounds like verizon or something
you know like exactly
that's a great way to learn a hated
company is to have a lot of features
that don't reliably work
all right here's the next one that was
written by yc founder
um they wrote
we copied another successful business
model from an overseas market
and wrongly assumed that product market
fit was a given if the product works in
country x it's going to work in country
y
we scaled up hiring quickly and burnt a
lot of money before we realized that the
users we were selling to did not want
our product
this is something that happens so
commonly and what's tricky
is that
investors often like funding these ideas
because they're so simple right
this is a very simple thesis if blank
works here it should work there so
oftentimes these companies like get
money
but then fail after getting money how
have you seen this
i think i think what we want to believe
is banners and this applied to me too
is that
by getting validation from
investors or the press or my friends or
employees or winning a startup
competition whatever
that meant it was good and that that was
the validation you know hey i've got
i've got validation
and
it's pretty frightening to realize
that you can get validation from all
those things and it could still not work
you know and that getting the stamp of
approval
like ultimately you're responsible for
the thing works or not
and no one it's like no one else's
problem to make it work other than the
founder you're kind of you're kind of on
your own on this one um
and so
it's almost like it's like thinking that
if you can pass the driver's license
test to get a driver's license it means
you're a good driver
like i think all of us that have a
driver's license know
you can still be a pretty bad you know
there's a lot of variation in the
quality of driving and lots of people
can get into trouble with their driving
habits even though you have a driving
license
there's no and there's no mechanism you
know unless you get pulled over like
things have to go bad or you get unlucky
for an authority figure to get involved
but for the most part you can get into
all sorts of trouble even though you
have a driver's license that's how i
view this
is that
you know you can have your startup
license hey i have a website i got you
know i got an article i i raise some
money
but man you can really do poorly
and no one's gonna stop you
yeah
i think this also comes
from historical context like by that i
mean
i still think that most founders are
kind of
looking back to what's worked in their
past
and almost everything that's happened in
their past almost everything they've
learned they didn't have to learn from
first principles they didn't have to
observe personally right you learn
physics from a physics teacher
and so i think what's so tricky is what
we're basically saying is that like all
of the ways that you learned in the past
don't work here you actually have to go
observe the problem
talk to the people who have the problem
try to figure out what's going on and
iterate
whereas like no one learns things that
way in school like no one's like hey
like we're gonna drop a rock off of a
building see it fall and then figure out
what happened right you never learn
physics that way and so i think that
what happens is that when these founders
go into startups they're looking for the
teacher
is the teacher is the cheat right like
how much harder would it be to learn
physics without the teacher right it's
funny
like you know people people email you
and me sometimes after these videos they
watch these videos and our whole point
is go talk to customers go figure it out
and they email us and they're like can
you give me advice
like they kind of aren't getting the
video the point of these videos at all
which is what we're saying which is a
little bit frightening
is that authority figures don't have the
answers for a lot of these questions and
if you're looking for authority figures
to tell you
your idea is good
you still aren't really getting the
point of these videos
we're kind of telling you
you have to
go
get ground truth answers
from customers and that you really can't
substitute anything for ground truth
answers no
it doesn't suck yeah that sucks
sorry i wish i could tell you that i had
all the facts
i feel like we can't make it not suck
but isn't it nice that we're just being
honest with you and being like this is
exactly how much it's gonna suck you
know it's not
it's not easy
what i find distressing though is how
investors often get this wrong
investors often believe that
founders don't need this ground truth or
you can just take solution from a and
put it in place b and work
give companies money
those companies start doing company
building
hiring the exacts hiring the team
and this happens why i see companies all
the time you know you talk to them two
years later and you're like you know
they come to you and they're like it's
not working and this happens why i see
companies a lot they'll go raise a lot
of money
ignore us for two years come back when
it's not working but they have a team of
50 and be like michael dalton like what
happened it's like well
did anyone like your pro like did you
solve any problem for anyone like
or like let's look at a core stat right
like you charge people what's your
revenue look like you're you know and
then well we're not really focused on
revenue right now we want to grow we
want to grow we have to increase the nu
we know this company personally i won't
say it is we have to increase the number
of customers who could buy us
before we increase
the customers who do buy us it's like
well
it's a great logic yeah it's good i do
what is comforting
to me though is that when the runway
gets down to about 12 months
the magical thinking starts
fading you know suddenly it's funny
don't you wish you could bottle up
like if you see someone's performance
say there's you know you have 18 months
of cash
the first like
you know 15 months
when someone's back is against the wall
the quality of their decisions get much
better if there is a way to like gamify
like if you bottle up the quality of
execution and thinking and like i don't
know we see people do great work
it's just you wish they would do this
great work when their back is not
against the wall again it reminds me of
being in college or something yes where
the papers do
yeah and you know you didn't go to the
class you didn't show up to anything
and then like in the final 24 hours you
like
you do great work
but you could have done that the whole
time and not had a whole fire drill
right is that a shame
it is a shame you know the only solution
that's worked for me
is just like do companies that have such
a hard time raising money that it's
always a fire truck
um but yeah you know
it comes back to you that like the best
founders are disciplined what you talked
about is that's discipline
right
that's doing the right thing when no
one's forcing to you or no situations
forcing you to and i think that
too often
genius is mistaken for discipline it's
like
you know a lot of people think oh this
person out executed all their peers
because they were smarter and it's like
that assumes the peers were actually
working on the thing they said they were
working on as opposed to like hiring and
going to conferences and talking to
reporters
disciplined to avoid the distractions um
i mean that should be comforting a lot
of people it's like yeah for every ounce
of discipline you have you can probably
lose five ten ounces of intelligence and
still outperform you know yeah that's a
great point it's funny how many people
that we see again let me think about how
to phrase it with like
you'd think they'd be really good at a
lot of things
but they i'm not sure what they do with
their time
they have a great resume but it appears
they just don't really do work
and the people that sit down and do the
focused work and again we all know what
this is like and think back to college
yeah you know lots of reasons to not
work on something
um if you could bottle up those moments
where you're actually doing focused work
the people that succeed just seem better
at that that's actually the criteria
that they seem better at if you if you
looked at their calendar if you shadowed
them or something
the folks that are really good at this
are just
better at doing focused work
there's kind of nothing else i mean at
least yeah
and by the way you can't you can't
really change your raw intelligence but
you can get better at this like this is
a little bit like working out like you
can
you know if doing focused work for
someone who likes to procrastinate is a
little bit painful the more they do it
the less painful it gets you know and so
hey you know smart people certainly have
an advantage but man hard workers
hard workers are dangerous
[Laughter]
hard workers are dangerous lazy people
are um
you know as a startup founder lazy
people lazy competitors
are your friends
yeah it's good when your competitors are
focused on the wrong things yeah um
along these same lines like
i wanted to i wanted to talk about what
we learned from uh hardware crowdfunding
a little bit yeah so so here's the
here's the issue
if you need to manufacture a lot of a
product
it's much cheaper to do a big order in
quantity right follow me like say we
want to let's talk about t-shirts let's
say we want to create dalton and michael
t-shirts it's much cheaper to do an
order for 10 000
than it is to do one at a time right of
the same t-shirt ten thousand seam
t-shirt yeah makes sense right and so
crowdfunding and kickstarter made sense
because you could raise you could sell
the t-shirts at once we actually had a
yc community that's called teespring
didn't work out but it was like a way to
order a bunch of t-shirts and a quantity
and um then you get a big pile of money
and then everything goes perfectly and
you engineer it and you manufacture the
product and all the backers of your
kickstarter get the product and
everyone's happy and you write you know
you right off into the sunset right
that's how it works right michael like
that's exactly and then you then you're
apple
again i don't think people are going to
get the irony we're being i'm i'm being
facetious for my foreign friends that
don't get the irony so in practice
michael what actually happens what do we
see with all these companies at
crowdfunding
no idea how to build it
no idea how much how much building it
would cost no no idea how much the thing
should cost
so they're charging users for a product
that they don't even know what the right
price is
the people who buy it have no idea how
long it's going to take to build which
is only matched by the people who are
building it having no idea how much it
takes to build
and we haven't even gotten to the best
part no idea whether the thing actually
solves the problem for the person
but a lot of money up front and god like
a lot of expectations
a lot of untested plans
you know
well that's
that's what's funny is like when you
think about it it seems like the
greatest thing in the world to be able
to raise money from a crowdfund for your
hardware company but in fact there's no
sure way to make strangers on the
internet
hate you
like like it's a really great way
to become like infamous on the internet
is to be like you know here's here's a
a cooler with a blender on it and it's
like 200 and back my kickstarter and
then you like don't ship it and like you
send out updates the dog ate your
homework and oh it's chinese new year
like i don't know like [ __ ] happens
and like man people don't people really
hate you you're like a villain for like
and thousands of people spend a lot of
time trying to like track you down yeah
and get the refunds and calling you a
scammer like it kind of we've seen this
ruin people we knows lives doing this
kind of thing
i think that
more and more there are other areas
of the startup world that are starting
to resemble this kind of model and i
think that
it's hard man it's it's so hard because
i remember the run-up to hardware if
you're a hardware company everyone else
was doing this
you look like an idiot if you weren't
crowdfunding you know and so like
it kind of goes back to the like hey man
sometimes when everyone's doing
something it doesn't mean that's gonna
work like yeah crowdfunding was what
like a six seven year cycle
yep and i think it still could be cool
like like there's situations where it's
a it's a tool i just think i think our
startups seven eight years ago thought
it was a panacea they thought it was the
solution yes like if you were a hardware
company the only way to do it was to do
a crowdfunding always
right and now it's just it's a tool that
you could bring to market but honestly
you know what the real story here is is
usually do it after you've shipped and
manufactured
a couple of versions already
like i think best practices if anyone
here is doing a hardware startup um
think best practices
is you don't do it at the early stages
and you do it later when you have like
v2 v3 and you're ready to manufacture at
scale because then you won't
create
thousands of enemies on the internet
that think you're trying to scam them
you know and again like all these people
had good intentions i don't think anyone
like no one was actually trying to scam
anyone
but intent doesn't matter to strangers
on the internet does it michael no you
know there is one better strategy
do a software company a lot easier
a lot easier yeah and then and then in
all things lines you know clearly
there's a lot of stuff happening in
crypto and this relevant to this but
just just be aware if you take money
from people
at scale
yeah on the internet they rightfully
will hold you accountable and i just
don't know if peop it looks like people
are handing out free money on the
internet and i get why people want that
just understand that there's a cost
and if people think that you you know
rugged them if you're if you rubbed the
people with your thing you know
it's gonna be bad for your life
right like there's a cost like there's
no there is no free lunch i think in
this sense and so
you know just be aware of that
i i don't and again i know people that
have been on the other side of this um
it's not great if they start trying to
track you down and it can change your
life forever
i mean like literally forever like like
there are a few things in the startup
world that kind of are like one shot
kill
and and you know this is one of them you
screw up with enough people's money
it never leaves you like you get that
permanent wikipedia page
that's not what's not what you want
all right well that was a good wrap up
great chatting dalton
you